all right a lot of ground to cover
tonight and the great one Mark Levin
will join us now we start with President
Trump reacting to the stunning news that
the FBI yes was fine
spying on the Trump campaign now this
has never happened before in American
history let's take a look
Congress would like to see documents
opened up a lot of people are saying
they had spies in my campaign if they
had spies in my campaign that would be a
disgrace to this country that would be
one of the biggest insults that anyone's
ever seen and it would be very illegal
aside from everything else it would make
probably every political event ever look
like small potatoes so we want to make
sure that there weren't I hope there
weren't frankly if they had spies in my
campaign during my campaign for
political purposes that would be
unprecedented in the history of our
country unprecedented in illegal now I
want to take what the president said one
step further this is how serious and
dangerous all of this is if we as a
country do not get to the bottom of this
and expose everything about these deep
state actors spying on an opposition
party during a presidential campaign
rigging one candidate email
investigation lying repeatedly to FISA
Court judges we will lose the country we
will destroy the rule of law we will
shred our constitution completely but
there is good news tonight that finally
the facts the truth are all starting to
come out as we've been predicting after
what is unprecedented stonewalling
obstruction slow-walking from rod
Rosenstein and the DOJ well a meeting
for Congress to finally see the
documents that they have been demanding
is set for Thursday now the House GOP
chairman Devin newness trey Gowdy
they're sitting down with the FBI
director Chris Ray the Director of
National Intelligence theyan Coates and
rod Rosen Stein's deputy of course and
for the record I do not trust rod
Rosenstein I'll explain also Sarah
Carter reporting that these documents
could hold the key and uncover every
single thing about what was done to the
Trump campaign and the Trump presidency
and being spied on and we believe that
is exact
why rod Rosenstein in the doj have been
obstructing and concealing what really
happened
now Rosenstein is trying to run out the
clock he hopes that democrats will
regain the house and this will all end
and go away now what is now apparent is
that Rosenstein is aiding and abetting
and what is nothing short of a cover-up
of the single biggest instance of abuse
of power and corruption in American
history and the media is right there
with them we have famed Harvard Law
Professor Alan Dershowitz been on this
show many times calling out the stunning
hypocrisy surrounding this deep State
scandal take a look if this had happened
to Hillary Clinton the ACLU would be
jumping up and down the way they did
when I was on the board of the ACLU
when undercover agents were put into the
anti-war movement into civil rights
movement all they were there was to
listen in to Muslim churches civil
libertarians are generally a little bit
suspicious when undercover agents go
just to ask questions and I think we as
a civil libertarians or to be suspicious
to this allay our suspicions and then
we'll be fine
checkmate professor Dershowitz he's
right now if this ever happened to
Hillary Clinton the media would be
apoplectic they would be demanding that
people go to jail but since it's Donald
Trump and the media doesn't care and
they hate Donald Trump well they have
actually been missing in action in
covering up this biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal they have ignored
every single crime that Hillary Clinton
has committed and the fact that she
bought and paid for a dossier put
together by a foreign national filled
with Russian lies and propaganda to
influence you the American people and
steal an election now the FBI then takes
that Clinton funded piece of garbage
Russian propaganda use it to get a FISA
warrant warrant to surveil on a trump
campaign associate and they did it by
lying to multiple FISA judges this is
the worst form of corruption now all of
that information is why tonight there's
over a dozen House Republican lawmakers
they need support they're signing on to
a resolution that calls for a second
special counsel to be appointed to
investigate all of these abuses now
abuses now congressman Ron de santis
he's one of those congressmen he's
reporting this and explaining why this
must happen which we have been saying
now for a long time take a look we also
need to get people to be held
accountable for any FISA abuse that
occurred and then how did this
investigation into the Trump campaign
start and wer was it on the up and up
from the very beginning there's always a
lot of questions about that and I don't
think that the Justice Department's
going to be able to investigate
themselves I think that they've resisted
our inquiries here in Congress for long
enough and so it's time that we did have
a special counsel well said and
Congressman Jim Jordan and Matt gates
also signed in this resolution they'll
join us on the program tonight but first
we know that days after the FBI put in
the fix and exonerated Hillary Clinton
exoneration before investigation they
immediately the same actors launched a
surveillance operation against the Trump
campaign and it gets worse
Byron York tonight reporting that these
new revelations about the FBI targeting
the Trump campaign is now leading to
very serious questions about when this
FBI investigation actually started now
we've been told that it began at the end
of July 2016 George papadopolis you know
drinking in a bar four-way drunken
hearsay that's not even admissible
hearsay in a courtroom never mind 4-way
and by the way it never made any sense
Washington Post now reporting that this
informant met with Carter page a few
weeks before the FBI says it officially
launched the probe their timeline isn't
matching up this is exactly why we need
the second special counsel and most
importantly we need an investigator
appointed who has prosecutorial powers
the DOJ Inspector General is now looking
than all of this rod Rosenstein wants
the Inspector General he cannot hold
these deep state actors accountable now
Michael Horowitz doesn't even have the
ability to convene a grand jury or issue
indictments the Clinton investigation we
still haven't gotten the report it's 18
months later guess what we don't have
that kind of time now what we need is a
full thorough complete criminal
investigation right now because you the
American people you deserve to know the
truth this has to be done for the sake
of this country tonight we're learning
even more stunning details about what
really has
but this is pretty shocking former Trump
campaign advisor Michael Caputo he's now
saying that there could have been
multiple informants multiple spies
targeting the Trump campaign here's what
he told our own Laura Ingraham last
night take a look let me tell you
something that I know for a fact the
this informant this person that they
planted tried to plant into the campaign
and even into the administration if you
believe Axios he's not the only person
that came at the campaign and the FBI is
not the only Obama agency that came at
the campaign I know because they came at
me and I'm looking for clearance to my
attorney to reveal this to the public
this is just the beginning and I'll tell
you when we finally find out the truth
about this director clapper and the rest
of them are going to be wearing some
orange suits I think he's right remember
that individual mr. Caputo remember he
came on this program and said oh after I
met with the special counsel he said
we'll be watching you on TV really mr.
Muller is that how you want to run your
investigation now we could have now
multiple spies multiple informants
chairman Nunez he's saying the exact
same thing and if you're shocked by that
take a look at what Caputo revealed
today take a look I was approached by an
intermediary but who had been talking to
a government official of former
government official who told him that
they had Hillary Clinton related emails
at the at that government organization
and that they wanted to get them to the
Trump campaign this was May 6 that he
heard that and 2016 I was told by the
intermediary on May 9th that they wanted
to get them to me I gave this
information to the House Intelligence
Committee I gave this information to the
Senate Intelligence Committee two weeks
ago and I gave this information to the
Muller team and they never reached out
to the intermediary to check on it oh so
they don't care it doesn't fit their
predetermined narrative now Caputo later
explained during that interview with
Neal that he turned down that offer for
Clinton's emails that is explosive
information and according to Caputo
Robert Muller you don't care about that
really maybe too busy thinking about
Paul Manafort 2005 taxes it explains
everything you need to know why this is
a witch hunt their goal has been to get
candidate Trump and now president Trump
it's plain and simple now the great one
Mark Levin he has something very
important to say about all of this later
tonight but first even more breaking
news to tell you about Senate Homeland
Security Committee Chairman Ron Johnson
he is demanding more information about
the FBI's apparent awareness that media
outlets had information about
Christopher Steele the foreign national
with Russian sources before the
president-elect Trump was even briefed
about it and according now - FBI emails
that Johnson's committee has obtained
the FBI had what they called a quote
sensitive matter team that was actually
communicating about the Steele dossier
now two days before CNN ran a story
about the dossier even in existence
Andrew McCabe deputy FBI director sent
this email subject line that read flood
is coming and then he goes on to write
CNN it's close to going forward with the
sensitive story the trigger for them CNN
is they know the material was discussed
in the brief and presented in an
attachment and what do you know CNN then
runs the story and then BuzzFeed
publishes that entire phony Russian
Clinton finance dossier now senator
Johnson is now demanding to know who was
a part of this sensitive matter team now
he's also asking for all of the
documents all the communications between
Comey James clapper and their staffs
regarding the Trump Tower dossier
briefing now remember the house Intel
committees report on Russia
it found that clapper the former
Director of National Intelligence leaked
information to CNN he now works for them
about the dossier it becomes a
contributor now on the fake news network
predictably he recently denied any
wrongdoing of course we already know you
lied on oath take a look I didn't have
any contact with media until after I
left the government on the 20th of
January so I don't quite understand at
least what I've read that somehow I
leaked about
the dossier so let me get so you didn't
leak anything about the dossier to any
media no not I mean I talked about it
after I left the government but not
during that period not and certainly not
between the 6th of January in the end
the 10th when the president-elect
himself talked about it yeah remember
that Christopher steel in
interrogatories in Great Britain under
oath said yeah it was raw intelligence
maybe 5050 true that becomes the basis
for a FISA warrant and clapper is now
firing back at the president course last
shouted at him and he doesn't like being
called the liar which he is let's watch
the president tweeted about you quote
clapper is a lying machine who now works
for fake news so a lot of people I know
first of all what was your reaction to
that when you first saw that well the
president's calling me a lying machine
well ok what that stems from is an
exchange I had with Senator Wyden five
years ago in March of 2013 about a
surveillance program and he was asking
me about one and I was thinking about
another so I made a mistake
I didn't lie oh just like Hilary made a
mistake she acid-washed our hard drive
as we've been saying clapper all of his
deep state friends have the right to
remain silent
I have some friendly advice I tried to
give it to Jim Comey stop talking lawyer
up a storm is coming
now demote a DOJ official Bruce or is
another one of these deep state minions
who is feeling the heat tonight the
Senate Judiciary Committee Chairman
Chuck Grassley he wants to see all the
communications between or and the former
British spy and dossier author
Christopher Steele remember or is the
guy who was in communication with Steele
both before and after the election and
it was or his wife Nellie she actually
worked for fusion GPS helped put
together the OP research and turned out
to be lies and Grassley now wants to
know of or was giving the FBI
information that Steele provided after
Steele was fired by the FBI for lying
about his contacts with the media all
right another big story were following
tonight we do have an update on the
nuclear showdown with a little rocket
man in North
riah Kim jong-un president Trump is now
saying the June 12 summit well might not
work out take a look there are certain
conditions that we want and I think
we'll get those conditions and if we
don't we don't have the meeting and
frankly it has a chance to be a great
great meeting for North Korea and a
great meeting for the world if it
doesn't happen maybe it'll happen later
maybe it'll happen at a different time
but we will see but we are talking the
meeting scheduled as you know on June
12th in Singapore and whether or not it
happens you'll be knowing pretty soon
but we're talking right now
the president's entire approach to these
talks has been we'll see what happens
and for all you haters of Trump out
there on the left you need to watch how
a pro negotiates as Trump has said in
his own book the art of the deal you
have to always be willing to walk away
up to the last second and I get it you
liberals you're upset because the
president isn't bowing and kissing the
ring of Kim jong-un and offering pallets
full of cash and other currencies like
the hundred and fifty billion Obama gave
the mullahs now if Kim jong-un wants to
come to the table then well the
president is willing to listen and if
Kim jong-un wants to threaten the world
like he was before well the president
will show a the force that he showed the
last time and we'll be back to where we
started now the president is reacting
from a position of strength let's see
he's given up nothing Kim jong-un is
making every concession and speaking of
those concessions North Korea is now
inviting international media to watch
their dismantling of their nuclear test
site and across the DMZ and he released
the hostages and we didn't pay him
anything right also great news for the
president tonight and Republicans in
Congress look at this the GOP now holds
an edge over Democrats in the generic
midterm ballot for the first time in a
brand-new Reuters poll look at that and
back in late April Democrats had a
ten-point advantage in that same poll
and in another poll they were 17 points
back Republicans were in January and
Nancy Pelosi may want to cancel those
plans about becoming the next speaker
this will be the most important midterm
election in our lifetime